this is how the world knows Ferguson
Missouri six months after the death of
Michael Brown protesters have retreated
and news crews have returned home but
the destruction in this riot torn town
remains if businesses leave eventually
the the community will dwindle down to
where it's non-existent are is desolate
and so it's important for businesses to
remain in the community some owners are
slowly reopening their stores but not
without personal sacrifice I took a hit
you know my savings account took a big
dip and I'm renting his face so you know
it was all on me gym owner Brian
Mitchell had to rely on his own cash and
a ten-thousand-dollar loan to clean up
smashed windows and convince customers
to return results after months of hard
work his boot camp is back to full
capacity we're changing labs that we can
one pound at a time my people expect me
to be open I do not close down the road
k pol is digging into her savings to
relocating her tax preparation business
to a trailer because her store has been
condemned this is just a building so the
building's gone but the spirit is still
here have you put a number on the damage
do you know how much this is costume it
costs about 20 grand to open initially
and then
to do this again we were out 32,000 the
economic impact of racially motivated
riots weighs heavily on communities
according to research that examined the
aftermath of the Rodney King riots
social catastrophes can cause more
long-term damage than a natural disaster
in the decade after those riots Los
Angeles lost almost four billion dollars
in taxable sales Ferguson's Mayor James
Knowles cancelled our interview and
refused to speak to us directly but his
spokesman sent us a statement saying
that city staff has been working closely
with business owners and investing in
the community yet some in Ferguson say
the support isn't coming fast enough the
response is very very slow so it has her
business I heard absolutely nothing from
anyone we were the ones who were
affected we were they need to come out
and make themselves see they need to
make themselves known come to me and say
hey what can we do to help you bring
your business back